这条视频告诉你该怎么做读书博书
没有可以读书博书更好的塞造了
可是我们大部分人的就做的读书
什么样的
都是错的
今天就有
我前两天有人问
我能够
读书博监读书
然后我可不可以读了
那我怎么面线
或者你要是自己就想变线
你变不了线
为什么
因为我们中国的大部分人
从七岁的时候就开始读书了
对吧
你已经打开直播见读书
谁不会啊
谁都会
你要是折的都能读
都能赚钱
没天灵
这件事情没有任何的互成歌
而且我跟大家讲
我们很多人读书的方法都是错的
然后我先把这个事放在这
以后告诉大家怎么去做
具体系列怎么做
我们讲另外一件事情
就是怎么还能卖东西
对吧
你不是卖书吗
你要赚线
变线嘛对吧
刚才有人问到这个问题
对不对
那我跟你讲
我以为说卖东西是最好的方法是什么
就是把自己觉得好的东西分享这边
对吧
比如说我失眠了
而且我用了一个什么东西
真的就不好了
我分享给你
对我用了一个战斗
我的战斗很好
对吧
要我等我用了什么东西
真的很好
我分享这边
这一种就是分享
你不会有任何的些的压力
而且好东西给别人冰箱
一定能才能夹着读书也一样
对吧
但是我们很能现在读书
变成什么样的
化条线
那样的东西
然后就指望变线
你这没有人是为了卖书的
可能卖书都不理
真的在卖书吗
不是吧
它是为的改变
当然也有
很能卖书是为的装飾的
但是那个没有用的
化了很多装
最后里边是超过的
没有用 对不对
所以最好的方法是什么
各位记住这句话
人能购买的是改变
而不是那个书
所以最好的方法是什么
就是你读这边是说
你改变了
你像我
我机会从来没有说
可是我没什么呀
兄弟们
我只要把书挂在那儿
我连推的委员员
人们就会买
为什么
因为我真的是通过
读书人生发生了改变
具体怎么做
说这么多飞的话
告诉你
就三目
三目
认真做啊
第一步
就是
每天读书的时候
不是所有的书都是想不到
每天必须有
这么一本书过来
这么一段书是干嘛的
不是去记录
不是这次思考
不是去记乡
不是去理解
就是做
未来
四十八个小时
那你马上给我行动
就认真怎么办
就是你行动了
没有
而不是你看了多少书
记得多少比记
化了多少
多么好看的
模特把什么
都是什么
不重要
第一件事情
做
四百产必须做
这是第一件事情
第二件事情
跟你记住
如果人真的想发生改变
这件事
一定要非常年载
如果这个事
行动就在很难这事就就别做了
就不要做了
所以我的建议是什么呢
当你帮你改变的时候
一定是把那个事做得很小很小
小事记得起来才能成大事
昨天每次都是那个力度
一定要分裂成为这个小
而且我告诉你的方法什么的
静好
静量副作在你已经成型那个喜欢上
比如说你每天都跑步
跑步回来以后读书
我其实又是这个样子
对吧
每天都刷水
刷水平之前读书
每天都明击
明亮之后读书
副作在你必须做某一定会做点事
这个事的前面会后面
来减手摸擦
另外一个方法是这么大摸擦
什么叫做大摸擦呢
我就跟我跟讲一个小事吧
就是我成统结果六思言
但是我是真的对六思就给接了
我以前也抽研的
我以前也喝酒的
现在是不抽研不喝酒
言已经接了十多年了
其中一个方法我告诉大家什么
当然我说我这个事是
这件事我量不着
其中有一部我给大家讲
也就是我跟所有人说
我是如果你们谁看了我抽研了
看了一次
一千块钱
我先把一半块钱放在身上
都管
看了一次
来的
但是之前啊
那时候我那个是我同时
怎么不搞啊
所以你触犯了以后你的这个
这个臭门太搞了
所以我当时有个习惯
就是一定我一到我下一段时间
你干什么
我一定会在打动
打听我弄下去去救公布
那么对你来说有什么用呢
对吧
不一弄钱
去个方法
比如说你每天都刷手机
每天都刷手机
倒把还刷手机
怎么
你把这个手机放在手机
跑工的构造的地方
或者是你刚才就
选择什么东西
晚上几天钟
往此动断
你马人了
自己都找不到
到那个点
你也上不了手机了
对吧
就是就是增加你的手机
这第二个不死
第二个不死
第三个不分干嘛
各位
修出来
怎么修
不要修你独论哪一个
书的那一段
修你的改变
就是我真的
看了不过书
修了某个东西
然后我的人生发生改变了
为什么发生改变了
我失败了点了
我哪一到考了
我原来以为是什么样子
现在是什么样子
然后我人生怎么改变的
只要你是
你真的
通过读书发生改变
你这说头过别特别好吗
你都不用买
把那个话不行
我就这样
你见过什么时候买书
但是我说可不少买
对不对
但这个事的
坏小气是什么呀
坏小气就是
你真的改变
然后你这个书才能买出去
再发过来
这个说
这不是好消息吗
你真的只有改变了以后
一才能把书买出去
所以做读书
博书是手段
改变
才是最终能表